And me,
what do you think about the menas?
What should be done with the menas,
in your opinion?
Well,
foreign menas,
minors
unaccompanied foreigners entering illegally.
"What needs to be done is to expel them and talk.
"
with the countries of origin to be expelled,
but above all
the only way to prevent them from arriving anymore,
because those who have arrived at times
it is difficult to repatriate them
because they do not recognize which one is
nationality.
But above all, launching
the message that
the one who enters our country illegally
will not be able to stay in Spain,
will not be able to regularize their situation.
And we also do this to defend
persons who have legally entered Spain
to work,
who have respected the procedures we have